There's a couple more things about
Android Build Variants that you should
know about, but you won't necessarily
need to use them very often.
Consider a game that contains
a great deal of drawable resources.
So many in fact that including
all the drawables for
every resolution would result
in an unacceptably large APK.
This would be an excellent time to use
product flavors, one for medium DPI and
one for high DPI.
Now, consider what happens if we
want to add free and paid flavors.
You'll want both a free and
paid medium DPI version, and a free and
paid high DPI version.
This comes out to four total flavors.
However, now if you want to include
additional functionality in
the paid version, for example,
you have to put it in two places.
One for the paid medium DPI and
one for the paid high DPI.
Now, suddenly we've lost all
the code release advantages of
using flavors in the first place.
Fortunately, the Android plug-in
supports the concept of flavor
dimensions to deal with this use case.
Just like the Android
plug-in will create tasks for
each combination of build type and
product flavor.
You will now be able to build every
possible permutation build type,
product flavor, and flavor dimension.